okay there's it's a weatherman
from channel 4 in the uk
uh oh you could just i don't know l.a
l.a would you want to hear it one time
and then try it okay let's let's let's
let the
liam dutton say that was pretty good
though but in the sunshine in north west
wales it's raf mona
just up the road from slander porsche
winger santos
that was awesome would you like to have
another that was awesome would you like
to have another crack at it if you
couldn't back up it's not going to read
it again
freeze back up there for the man there
you go
hey seriously though can we hear it
pronounce again i want it yeah you want
to hear it again
i do for real all right let's hear it
i'm slammed by the first winger go get
it
first of all if you live that place
you've got to potentially get that
change
yeah that's just stupid there it is yeah
listen
it doesn't say robin williams in there
it does
yeah rob will almost groceries
you could probably you could probably
find a lot of different words
it'll go gadget yeah anyway that was uh
i'm sure you at home found that as
entertaining as we did you could not
pronounce that until you were an adult
look kenny diabetes
well that's what they sell your shack
soda oh no shaq soda's done
[Laughter]
what is that all right that's a dog man
that's a wrap
that's a dog man and uh and i believe
that's a wrap for inside the nba
gracias police
oh that's just copyright 20. good try
shaq that was it was close